[Musique]
au bonheur des livres vous avez une
chance Inoué car vous avez la plus douée
des primos romancières et ma doue alors
ma cher Emma vous allez m'aider car vous
êtes hollandaise ou d'origine
hollandaise et je suis absolument un in
capable de prononcer votre nom je vais
essayer von trutm presque c'est pres ça
pres
rediteslemoi bon donc j'ai complètement
raté et le livre s'appelle ceux qui
appartiennent au jours c'est un roman
absolument
sublime sur une famille de pasteurs qui
vit en France qui est un peu la vôtre un
roman qui est bien dans la lignée et des
éditions de min à savoir une économie de
moyen une très grande poésie je vous
présente votre voisin S Landon 11 livres
si je dis une dizaine il va me
une barff alors vous voyez l'enragé ce
n'est pas lui c'est l'histoire de son
héros qui est un personnage donc enfermé
très jeune à bellî en mer car vous savez
que Fouquet à bellî en mer a construit
une forteresse qui n jamais habité à B
mer forteresse qui a été fabriquée par
Vau ban et tout ça a donné lieu à une
sorte de bagne dans lequel on a mis des
vrais bagnards alors ça c'est au fil du
temps des faux bagnards des enfants des
gens qui sortaient de l'Assistance
publique et là il s'agit
d'une grande évasion que vous raconte
avec son talent Sorge Chalandon que je
salue bonjour Sorge c'est publié aux
éditions Grassis et c'est tout le récit
de cet endroit et évidemment de cette
grande évasion je vais commencer par une
question pour Sorge après on va passer
au livre des m et après on va développer
Sorge tout le monde sait que vous êtes
journaliste vous avez passé une grande
partie de votre vie à Libération et
maintenant au Canard Enchaîné est-ce que
cette histoire de jeanbud celui que vous
appelez la est-ce que c'est une histoire
et de tous les personnages qui dirigent
ce bagne pour enfant est-ce que c'est
une histoire qui est une histoire que le
journaliste a dégoté comme un historien
c'est une histoire que le journaliste a
dégoté comme un historien et que
l'enfant que je suis qui é un enfant
battu a tardé à écrire donc je pense que
j'aurais dû l'écrire beaucoup plus tôt
j'ai pas pu le faire j'ai pas voulu le
faire j'ai pas eu envie de le faire mais
en tout cas j'ai j'ai appris que que ce
bagne avait fermé en 1977 mais en 62 6
mon père me disait qu'il m'y enverrait
donc en fait mon père m'a donné l'idée
c'est horrible ce truc là ah c'est
horrible c'està dire que mon père en
6263 m'avait dit et ça je je le cite
c'est une phrase qui est assez
terrifiante mais qui m'avait dit on
appelait ça maison de redressement ou
maison de correction à l'époque il avait
dit et il y en a une qui est pire que
les autres et où on te mettra pour ne
plus jamais revoir ta gueule elle est en
Bretagne au milieu de l'océan et quand
on met les gamins là-bas ils reviennent
jamais et donc sans qu'il le sache il
m'a donné l'idée à l'époque donc j'avais
10 ans 11 ans 12 ans il m'a donné l'idée
un jour peut-être de travailler sur ces
enfants qui ont effectivement été mis là
voilà ça a été donc ça se passe dans les
années 30 enfin donc la TH le héros
arrive en 1927 il repartira donc en 1937
protégé par un marin on va vous
expliquer il va vous raconter tout ça
euh et c'est vraiment d'une violence
inoui c'estàd que c'est à la fois un
roman qui est dans la veine de Jules
valz de Victor Hugo c'estàd au fond ce
qu'on aime dans la littérature française
classique c'est défendre les pauvres les
opprimés face évidemment à la répression
en tout cas une école de la littérature
française il y a un petit côté fouco
aussi sur l'enfermement comme désastre
absolu et en même temps il peut pas
s'empêcher de nous faire du Tarantino
parce que c'est quand même hyper hyper
violent alors vous ma cher ma on va
commencer par vous puisque vous êtes la
plus jeune et la plus douée je disais
tout à l'heure ceux qui m'appartiennent
au qui appartiennent au jour roman donc
aux Éditions de Minuit euh il faut
d'abord expliquer le titre maintenant
que vous avez prononcé votre nom que ni
Sorge ni moi sommes capables de
reprononcer une seule fois donc je vous
appeler em pendant toute l'émission très
bien pourquoi ce titre le titre est venu
assez tard et il y a tout un travail
dans le dans le livre sur les
expressions idiomatiques et leur
traduction en néerlandais en français et
ça c'est une traduction aussi d'une
expression néerlandaise qui
ditor et qui veut dire littéralement
c'est des hommes du jour et on dit ça
des personnes âgées dont on ne sait pas
si elles vont passer la nuit donc c'est
l'histoire d'une jeune femme je commence
par le début il faut être simple et lire
les livres c'est l'histoire d'une jeune
femme qui euh est en train d'assister ou
de participer à des répétitions euh de
the father donc la pièce célèbre qui a
donné un film célèbre et qui a eu un
Oscar euh célèbre et cette jeune femme
donc décide d'aller revoir sa famille
euh qui est en France dans un petit
village un peu perdu où il y a à la fois
le grand-père la grand-mère le père la
mère et le frère Nicolas qui est sur le
point de se poser la question de savoir
si lui aussi va reprendre euh cette
tradition familiale qui est celle d'être
pasteur est-ce que c'est quelque chose
qui a un caractère autobiographique
alors il y a des choses de moi dans le
livre et je pense surtout quand on écrit
un premier roman que on parle beaucoup
aussi de de ce qu'on connaît euh mais
j'avais envie d'écrire une fiction donc
c'est un roman et ce qu'il y a de moi
dedans c'est peut-être que ma mère est
pasteur et que j'ai le point de départ
du livre c'était la démence de mon grand
père donc j'ai commencé à écrire à
partir de ça et au fur et à mesure en
eff fait de Montag de de superposition
d'images que je voyais que je récoltais
c'est devenu une fiction et une espèce
de fable mais vous savez que vous êtes
surdoué ou pas on vous j'esp je vous
dire je vous lis mais c'est pas grave
hein alors d'abord il y a des justement
à propos des des différences entre le
français et le néerlandais il ne
faudrait pas dire nature morte il
faudrait dire vie silencieuse donc il y
a tous les deux ou trois ch apitre comme
ça des expressions qui
appartiennent idiomatique qui
appartiennent à nous les français ou à
Emma perdre la tête perdre son chemin
voilà exactement c'est très beau et par
exemple à propos de son père au début du
livre papa ne bouge pas le lit a pris la
forme de son corps une forme trop grande
celle des anges que l'on devine dans la
neige donc si vous voulez quand on lit
ça chez une jeune fille qui a près 25
ans si M leses renseignements sont bons
on se dit celle-elà il ne faut pas la
rater il faut il faut lire ce livre donc
vous les retrouvez et le moins qu'on
puisse dire au début c'est qu'il y a une
certaine forme d'énigme même si c'est un
livre poétique parce que ils sont dans
un
état physique et moral les uns et les
autres les grands-parents les parents et
les enfants très différents h oui c'est
c'est un livre que j'ai essayé de
construire comme un puzzle ou comme un
Memory parce que moi ça m'amuse beaucoup
les jeux de société et donc il y a cet
effet de fragment et qui effectivement
on entre dans le livre qu' on entre dans
une énigme et on comprend pas très bien
ce qui se passe au début et il y a ces
trois générations là effectivement qui
sont dans des états très différents et
que je vois un peu comme des variations
sur le même thème qui est celui de de la
mémoire quoi h voilà et surtout quelque
chose qui m'a frappé c'est qu'en général
les les jeunes gens de votre génération
qui écrivent les premiers livres sont
souvent autobiographiques mais parlent
aussi souvent de la vie du monde le
monde actuellement justement Hollande
c'est quand même les narcotrafiquants
qui menacent la famille royale le
Premier ministre et cetera dont on se
dit Emma peut peut-être parler de ça
bien non elle parle des pasteurs c'est
qu'on a l'impression d'être confronté
brutalement à rambran à Vermer à toute
la peinture hollandaise à un monde
traditionnel silencieux poétique et
lointain oui et il y a cette idée aussi
que j'avais envie d'explorer de d'un
monde qui disparaît et qui est en train
de disparaître et qui est en H cllos et
qui le monde voilà religieux aussi et
qui par métaphore et aussi juste le
monde contemporain dans lequel on vit
qui brûlait jusqu'au bout et c'est la
question de qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec ça
et qu'est-ce qu'on construit il y a une
chose qui m'a beaucoup touché c'est que
non seulement il y a l'impression par le
biais de la littérature qu'on assiste
justement à des natures mortes
d'ailleurs vous parlez beaucoup de de ça
sans parler de peinture mais en tout cas
on a ce sentiment là et al surtout tout
ce beau monde qui est quand même gagné
par une certaine forme de tristesse
c'est qu'il est aussi gagné par la
musique c'est-à-dire que on chante il
vous arriêve de danser sur Elvis prley
c'est qu'il y a une sorte de
confrontation entre jeune femme qui
vient de ses répétitions avec la famille
qui leur apporte une certaine forme de
gé oui mais la musique était très
importante dans le livre je crois parce
que d'abord c'est des personnes qui
disent mieux que moi des choses que
j'avais envie d'exprimer et et que j'ai
la sensation que parfois quand on ne
sait pas quoi dire on écoute de la
musique et on chante mais la mère est
flutiste de jazz par elle joue oui elle
est flutiste et elle joue non seulement
de enfin elle elle elle chante maelson
mais elle joue de la elle joue de la
flute version jazz oui oui et a un
rapport aussi peut-être du
protestantisme à la musique on chante
beaucoup chez les protestants pourquoi
ah pourquoi je sais pas mais là j'ai
j'ai une j'ai une phrase de Max porter
qui a rien à voir mais qui dit he wants
to kill things so he sings et c'est
peut-être ça c'est un espèce de de
remède contre la mélancolie et peut-être
que les PR protestants sont très
mélancoliques je sais pas ce qui m'a
aussi intéressé c'est que je me suis
rendu compte je sais pas si S je connais
bien la littérature hollandaise mais moi
je ne la connais pas c'est autant la
peinture hollandaise j'allais dire là on
a parlé des grands classiques mais on
pourrait aller van Gog exposition
extraordinaire à HS mondriillant enfin
on sait ce que c'est que la peinture
hollandaise aujourd'hui y compris la
peinture qu'en mais les an Enquist alors
j'ai recherché les
sakort les Joris beaucoup de gens de la
littérature sont pratiquement inconnus
en France comment ça se fait on conna
les suédois maintenant via le polarard
on connaît évidemment la tradition de la
littérature allemande les
Anglais comment se fait-il que la
littérature hollandaise qui est quand
même de très grande qualité soit un peu
minorée en France c'est une bonne
question à laquelle j'ai pas pas de
réponse mais c'est vrai que c'est un
constat que j'ai fait aussi qu'il y a
beaucoup de livres néerlandais que que
j'aime notamment de poésie qui sont pas
du tout traduit en français quoi donc
peut-être que ça ça laisse la
possibilité de les traduire ces livres
là est-ce que vous avez choisi les
émissions de minuit ou ce sont les parce
que c'est c'est un monde très
particulier celui des émissions de
minuit c'est bquet enfin c'est quand
même c'est c'est Chenau sont des gens
c'est bien non mais c'est c'est très non
non mais c'est très très bien mais c'est
c'est d'une certaine manière c'est
l'aristocratie de la littérature en
France ouais mais je pense que c'est
c'est des des rencontres des occasions
qui se créent mais c'est vrai que moi il
y a beaucoup de d'auteurs et d'autrices
fondamentaux pour ma construction qui
sont de minuit je pense ou à bqu ça
resse à tous ces gens-l à DELEUSE c'est
c'est des textes qui m'ont construit
donc ça met la pression aussi de se dire
oh là là il y a tout cet héritage là
quoi voilà donc c'est un c'est un roman
qui est extrêmement réussi il faut pas
tout dévoiler parce qu'autrement c'est
le ridicule des émissions littéraires si
on raconte absolument tout ce qui a
écrit Emma doue pour le reste je la
laisse faire pour le reste de son nom
vous perdrez le charme et vraiment c'est
un livre qui fonctionne sur le charme
sur la poésie sur les silences et la
musique sur ce voyage et puis le retour
parce que vous avez à la fin du livre
évidemment vos copains qui sont restés
là-bas qui rentre on a besoin de toi tu
nous manque et et en tout cas ce manque
a donné ce livre qui est une réussite
totale je le remontre et nous allons
passer à l'autre livre qui est celui
donc de mon camarade Sorge Chalandon
commençons par le commencement Sorge
vous vous inscrivez d'ailleurs
directement puisque vous citez Jules
valess dans une tradition littéraire
c'est valè Hugo euh
vous citez Jean Valjean à de nombreuses
reprises dans le Liv c'est une histoire
cette histoire de ce bagne de Belline en
mer dans les années 30 avec des gosses
qui ont des subiss des sévices
épouvantables vous l'inscrivez dans un
cadre littéraire qui est un cadre
littéraire français classique connu oui
classique connu qui peut être j'ai même
entendu certains qui disaient que
c'était chiant c'estàd que c'était
c'était ancien c'était poussiéreux il y
avait plus aucun intérêt tant pis c'est
ce que j'aime faire c'est ce que je sais
faire c'est ce que je lisais quand
j'étais petit ce qui est important c'est
que juste un mot parce que dans dans le
livre d'ma il y a un grand-père op pas
il y a une grand-mère OMA ce que cet
enfant ce que Jul n'aura pas n'aura
jamais c'estàd qu'il y a de l'amour dans
ce livre là qu' n'y a pas dans mon livre
à moi c'estàdire que j'aurais eu cet
amourl C OPA C Thas ce père ce frère
cette mère je pense pas que j'aurais pu
écrire ce livre là c'est c'est un livre
né
sans sans amour sans tendresse et c'est
important c c'est-à-dire que on on ne
peut pas euh on on ne peut pas aimer
Jules valet si on peut bien sûr toujours
on peut faire n'importe quoi mais je
pense que pour aimer Jules valè il faut
qu'il y ait une une part de souffrance
en soi qui fait qu'on se sente proche il
y a combien de gosses dans se bagne de
il y en a eu jusqu'à 4 500 euh et et et
donc pourquoi il s'appelle Jules mon
petit personnage c'est justement parce
que moi je je viens d'une famille sans
culture sans culture c'est il y avait
pas de livre il y avait pas de s'il y
avait deux livres il y avait il y avait
une biographie d'Adolf Hitler et un
livre sur LAF SS c'est tout deux livres
dans toute la maison il y a pas de
musique il y avait pas de littérature
c'est ce que vous avez écrit dans mon
salot voilà c'est ça c'est c'est-à-dire
que euh et et et donc ce qui fait rire
mes filles j'ai deux filles aujourd'hui
en basage enfin jeune ce qui les fait
rire c'est que je lisais en cachette et
j'allais à la bibliothèque à Lyon donc
c'est pour ça que mes filles ça les fait
marrer parce que je lisais des livres en
cachette ellees jou à TikTok en cachette
les livres en cachette elles comprennent
même pas ce que c'est c'est parce que
une bibliothécaire m'avait offert
l'enfant et que il y a cet exerg de
Valais que j'ai tenu à mettre en début
de ce livre là c'est pour ça que je l'ai
appelé Jules parce que j'avais valesse
lorsque j'étais enfant il m'a offert son
petit Jules valess il m'a il m'a offert
l'enfant il m'a offert cette souffrance
là il fallait qu'en retour je lui offre
mon Jules bonau donc mon petit
personnage et que je lui offre comm mon
comm mon comm on remercie donc je je
remercie Valès parce que c'est terrible
de d'être enfant battu d'être enfant euh
châtier
abîmé lacéré par un père et tout d'un
coup on se rend compte qu' un petit Jul
va laisse quelque part qui a vécu la
même chose et qui te dit e gamin tu es
pas seul et ça c'est génial je voudrais
qu'on plonge dans le livre comme on a
plongé tout à l'heure dans celui des Mar
alors à un moment donc la teigne il a
affaire au gardien il y a un patron de
de ce bagne qui est une espèce
d'aristocrate qui ne met pas ça Légion
d'honneur qui la réserve au monde
extérieur mais qui est d'une fermeté
terrible al avant de refermer la porte
sur moi les trois autres il a lâché
messieurs la taigne est à vous j'avais
joué j'avais perdu céta le prêt à payer
les trois gaffes s'entendit bien ils
avaient l'habitude de porter des coups
ensemble pied et point le premier m'a
donné un coup de tête pour que je
m'effondre je vais plus loin j'ai pensé
à des bûcherons conseneux pas un cri pas
une insulle pas un mot il frappait comme
on fait son travail cuisse dos bras il
s'appliquait et chaque coup portait
raisonnait de ma nuque à mon ventre au
premier sent il s'arrêtait au nest les
gardiens donc me l'avait expliqué dès
que je suis tombé j'ai mordu violemment
ma joue puis ma langue exprès la douleur
m'a fait presque oublier leur brutalité
bref le goût métallique du sang pour les
faire arrêter et puis ça com parce que
les les les la scène de révolte finale
de tous ces gamins
d'oui la thne il tombe amoureux mais au
sens de l'amitié d'un jeune homme qui
s'appelle l'oiseau ouais qui
malheureusement est un jeune homme
extrêmement fragile qui sera utilisé
sexuellement par les gardiens et et par
d'autres enfants qui sont dans le bagne
par les caïd voilà et donc
lathè se sent très proche de cet enfant
qui à un moment au moment de l'évasion
va se réfugier ses deux sœurs pour
lesquelles il a travaillé donc qui sont
des des gens de Bay l' mer Bay en mer
c'est 17 km le palais la capitale Suson
Locmaria c'est c'est c'est la deuxè île
française si on compte pas au léron
parce qu'il y a un pont mais c'est un
petit monde sublime d'ailleurs un
mitéran dis que c'était en roit le plus
beau qu'il avait jamais vu et euh cette
violence aussi quand il essaye ce petit
oiseau d'aller se réfugier che les dames
chez qui il a travaillé pour échapper au
gardien elle le balance c'est que les
illiens balancent ces gens du bagne et
il n'y a aucune solidarité sauf ce
pêcheur qui va sauver Jules alors non
seulement il y a qu'une solidarité mais
une véritable chasse à l'enfant a été
organisée par les autorités sur l'île
donc nous sommes le 27 août 1934 et tous
les liens et il est depuis 27 il est oui
absolument et tous les ENS y compris les
touristes se sont mis à la chasse à pour
25 fr à l' enfant alors pour 20 francs
une pièce de 20 francs argent qui
représentait à l'époque quand même
quatre pains de 3 de 3 kg donc il y a
ceux qui sont allés pour l'argent ceux
qui sont allés en refusant la pièce pour
la loi et l'ordre et ceux qui sont allés
pour jouer il y avait tous les chasseurs
qui s'étaient habillés en chasseurs et
qui ont chassé les enfants avec les
fusils donc ce qui est étonnant c'est
qu'on est en 34 bientôt la guerre arrive
et sur une petite île sur un petit
périmètre comme ça il y a eu des
collabos il y a eu des résistants parce
qu'il y a eu évidemment des gens il y a
eu des justes si je peux dire qui ont
donné une couverture ici du pain à un
enfant sans en faire plus mais en tout
cas qui ne supportait pas que des
enfants de 12 à 21 ans soit comme ça
dans la nature et soit rapporté
violemment ramené à la citadelle pour
une pièce de 20 francs on a acheté des
ENF c'est d'ailleurs le cas donc du
marin pêcheur qui recueille Jul ronand
qui est avec sa femme Sophie on perdu un
enfant il se solidarise une partie à ça
c'est le côté un peu militant mais assez
marrant c'estàd que ceux qui travaillent
sur la chaloupe il y en a deux qui sont
proches de la CGT ce qui est quand même
assez c'est assez bizarre mais c'est
surtout ce que vous racontez dans
l'épilogue c'est que le caractère qui
est celui de Jules bonau qui a été formé
je lis l'épilogue on a le droit parce
que finalement l'essentiel de suspense
est dans le livre il est pas à la fin
oui puis il est paru il y a un moment
déjà bon Jules bonau ma ché emma a été
arrêté en janvier 42 par une patrouille
dearmée allemande rue De Robien à Renn
surpris en train de sectionner des
câbles téléphoniques militaires torturé
par la guestapo il avoura deux
tentatives d'incendie contre le Comité
d'action antibolchevique et de la rue
chalotet et le bureau de recritement de
la VA boulevard de la Liberté il a
déclaré avoir agi seul sans lien avec la
résistance locale il a été fusillé le 14
décembre 1942 à Saint Jacques de la
landande au lieu d' la Maltière il avait
28 ans c'est un
destin je dis tragique c'est le mot est
faible alors tragique oui et non
tragique oui bien sûr mais en même temps
c'est un garçon qui n'a jamais voulu
adhérer à quoi que ce soit il a jamais
été dans un groupe jamais même dans la
résistance il est seul et surtout je
pense c'est un homme droit un homme à la
nuque raide c'est-à-dire que sa vie
entière il a été le contraire de ce que
le bagne a voulu faire de lui
c'est-à-dire un soumis un docile jamais
il a toujours levé les yeux toujours
levé le front il s'est toujours battu
mais toujours seul et c'est ça que
j'aime chez chez lui c'est que il il ne
cherche ni l'adhésion des autres ni la
gloire ni la beauté ni l'éphémère il il
sait où il va mais il y va seul et
j'aime beaucoup ça je voudrais qu'on
donne et on va converser
avec notre autre invité il faudrait
qu'on donne là euh les noms des gens
parce que on est dans le roman donc il
faut savoir qu'il y a les gardiens
pierre Legoff Napoléon
chautan il y a évidemment c'est la
colonie de haute Boulogne elle porte un
nom il faut voir ce fort de vauan qui
surplombe la ville du palais qui est en
gros la capitale de bé en mer c'est un
endroit absolument phénoménal il y a il
y a donc le personnage central qui
dirige tout ça il faut donner son nom
qui est une sorte d'Aristo perdu de
passagees
euh qui est le le patron du bagne quoi
alors il d'abord ce qui est important
c'est que moi j'ai le journaliste
derrière moi qui empêche l'auteur de
faire n'importe quoi c'està dire que je
veux que tout soit absolument exact que
cette évasion elle soit exacte que ces
lieux soient justes que je ne veux pas
qu'il manque un bouton de guêre au
gardien je veux que tout soit avant de
faire rentrer un personnage de fiction
je veux que tout le reste soit soit
totalement vrai et quand ce personnage
de fiction par exemple va être avec des
marins pêcheurs de des sardiniers en 34
est-ce qu'on pêchit la sardine en 34 à
sauson oui c'est que Bellil c'est tout
une éocation alors vous parliz tout à
l'URE de votre plage on va converser
ensemble de cette plage qui ouvre le
livre parce que c'est à la fois la mer
la Hollande évidemment les PO d' puis en
même temps il se réfugi en France donc
il y a ce mélange entre les deux mais
Belly en mer c'est je prends le
traducteur de Joyce vivait enfermé à
Belly en mer Sarah Bernard Belly en mer
François miteranti a comment Arletti
aussi oui Arletti qui était sur la plage
de donant qui avait sa maison qui était
aveugle la Bell de l'EN mer donc il y
avait ce mélange incroyable et aussi
quelque chose qu'on a totalement oublié
qui était une décision de justice qui
était en tout cas dans ma génération
donc la nôtre les interdits de séjour
sur le continent c'est une condamnation
que vous aviez et ça concernait
notamment un certain nombre de violeurs
quand vous arrivez à bellille vous aviez
le bar de la frégate qui est sur le port
du palais et vous aviez beaucoup de gens
qui étaient des condamnés et qui étai
des gens qui avaient qui étaient des
délinquants sérieux plus ceux qui
étaient dans dans dans donc c'est un
climat ultra poétique c'est pour ça que
miteran dit c'est un des plus beaux
endroits du monde pasain par monnaie les
aiguilles de porortcoton mais en même
temps ultra violent enfin compliqué à
l'image de l'océan je trouve ah oui bah
ça vous dites que c'est la prison c'est
la fois sublime et à prison bien sûr
bien sûr justement quel rapport a ce
pays qui est très
impliqué Emma par par la mer donc la
Hollande dans l'envie d'écrire éire ou
la façon d'écrire
ah c'est une question
compliquée j'ai un rapport très fort à
la mer je mais ça se sent c'est pour ça
que je vous pose la question une
certaine forme de fluidité oui c'est ça
c'est en même temps c'est de se sentir
tout petit devant l'immensité et en même
temps c'est une certaine forme de de
fluidité de quelque chose qui s'arrête
jamais de de remou de vague et peut-être
qu'il y a ça dans l'écriture aussi c'est
des phrases assez courte mais je je fais
hyper attention à au rythme et ça peut
être des espèces de petites vague les
phrases donc c'est peut-être là le
rapport à la mer et est-ce que votre
génération est est frappée par ce que
nous les journaliste traitons concernant
justement la langue aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire ce climat qui s'est ultra
durci avec l'arrivée de vildor au
pouvoir le départ de Marc rout qui
lui-même était quand même directement
menacé physiquement par les
narcotrafiquants qui qui qui qui débat à
Rotterdam ou utilise le port de
Rotterdam il y a même problème en
Belgique mais ils en sont à à menacer la
famille royale est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qui vous touche qui touche tous
ceux qui viennent de ce pays magnifique
dont les noms sont imprononçbles ah bah
totalement je je suis allée au Pays-Bas
un peu par hasard juste après l'élection
les élections et c'était la première
fois que je me suis senti néerlandaise
parce que je me sens pas néerlandaise et
je me sens pas de appartenir à une
nationalité et là je me suis senti
néerlandaise et j'avais honte de l'être
et j'avais envie de dire à tout le monde
je n'ai pas voté pour cet Hommel parce
que c'est c'est un pays qui qui est en
train de prendre un tournant mais comme
tout toute l'Europe et voilà c'est un
peu à l'échelle de ce qui se passe dans
le monde aujourd'hui qui est en train de
prendre un tournant ultra violent
euh et ultra oui voilà c'est j'ai pas
envie d'appartenir à ce mondelà et voilà
donc j'avais envie de c'est pour ça vous
êtes reféfugié dans la poésie d'une
certaine manière oui je crois que c'est
un refuge et je crois que c'est une
espèce de position de oblique pour mieux
regarder la réalité aussi la violence
vous avez commencé non pas votre
carrière dans la violence mais quand
vous étiez envoyé spécial en Irlande
pendant la guerre avec les Britanniques
justement entre l'IRA les Britanniques
c'est aussi là que comme que que non
seulement on vous êtes devenu le grand
journaliste s Chalandon c'est pas du
tout la flag idiote mais en même temps
un peu l'historien justement de de cette
guerre de 100 ans parce que l'histoire
entre les Irlandais et les Anglais ça
durait 100 ans pratiquement tout le 20e
siècle 800 ans en fait enfin pour la
partie que j'ai connu pour la partie que
nous avons connu con non mais moi ce qui
ce qui me touche et c'est extrêmement
rare c'est que les terroristes d'hier
sont les ministres aujourd'hui c'est
extrêmement rare pour un homme pour moi
par exemple d'aller voir des copains en
prison et aujourd'hui d'aller les voir
dans les ministères ouais c'est c'est
comme Mandela en Afrique du Sud voilà
exactement ce que jeallais dire il y a
l'Afrique du Sud et l'Irlande
imaginons-nous alors j'ai un rêve comme
dirait le trèsbe Luther King
imaginons-vous imaginons-nous un un
ministre un un militant palestinien en
prise
demain ministre de la Culture en Israël
juste imaginons-nous ça c'est impossible
bah apparemment si il y a des pays où
c'est possible nous allons vous
présenter quelques livres le le dernier
roman de Yannick Enel il va sortir il va
venir prochainement au bonheur des
livres il a écrit un livre sur bacon et
il viendra avec le grand peintre
espagnol Miguel Barcello donc c'était le
Trésorier Payeur Régis JF c'est le bah
c'est le provocateur des lettres
françaises il y a pas d'AES donc je vous
lis tout simplement avant le début vous
allez comprendre de juillet 1888 à avril
1889 Clara Hitler porte dans son ventre
celui qui est destiné à devenir
l'incarnation du mal absolu vous avez
compris de quoi il pouvait s'agir
joffrein n'en rate pas une mais il a un
talent fou Johan SP évidemment c'est une
star vous le savez de de la bande
dessinée euh alors là ce sont des choses
qu'il a fait quand il faisait les études
d'art donc au fond vous trouverez euh
euh ce qu'on trouve chez beaucoup
d'artistes une sorte de carnet de bord
où il y a à la fois des dessins et en
même temps des textes parfois d'ailleurs
très longs sont les carnets de Johan
SPAR et c'est depuis le début de sa
carrière 1992 à 2000 et puis pour sarat
est un homme que nous aimons beaucoup
vous savez qu'il a été frappé donc par
un accident et qu'il passe sa vie lui
qui était et qui est toujours d'ailleurs
la générosité même le et bien qui passe
sa vie dans une petite chaise la
jeunesse du monde c'est pour ça qu'il
parle du destin brisé de Gautier et de
Vincent malerau il se trouve qu'il avait
écrit un livre récemment sur Dely Gones
puisqu'il était à l'école avec Doly
Gones à versaill donc il avait écrit un
GR roman qui lui était consacré je vous
remercie vraiment d'être venu mais merci
à vous Sorge merci 1000 fois ça me
rappelle des vieux souvenir mais Emma
vous allez être obligé de nous redonner
votre nom en entier car après tout nous
aimons bien entendre chanter le
Hollandais de temps en temps ah ben
c'est
Emma merci à tous les deux
[Musique]
Ciao